etonnant non qu'on me permette
exceptionnellement de consacrer cette
chronique à l'expulsion d'un remords qui
me ronge
je voudrais présenter ici mes excuses
aux poulains le pangolin est un
mammifère édenté d'afrique et d'asie
c'est une bête éminemment pacifique de
ma vie je n'ai jamais eu à me plaindre
d'un pont gaulle pourtant dans un petit
livre que j'ai publié il ya plus d'un an
et dont je vous recommande vivement
d'éviter la lecture je m'étais permis de
porter un jugement sans doute blessant
et péjoratif visant à discréditer
l'image publique de ce paisible
quadrupède comme ça pour faire sourire
pour vendre du papier
brassens par la suite repris par le
tourbillon de la vie mon travail mes
amours ma santé préoccupante puisque à
46 ans passé je n'ai toujours pas de
cancer
j'avais fini par oublier le pangolin or
mercredi dernier l'un des prétendants de
ma fille il n'a pas fini de prétendre
maisonneuve en chacun l'un des
prétendants de ma fille donc est entré
furibard dans mon bureau
le livre en question à la main dis donc
t'es vraiment [ __ ] avec les pangolins
après lui avoir fait remarquer que ce
n'était pas là le ton convenable pour
s'attirer les grâces d'un beau père
potentiel
je fini par lui accorder un bref
entretien sur celui de mes genoux
n'était pas le chat pauvre paul golain
regarde ce que tu as écrit et en effet
la relecture je ressentis comme une
méchante attention de blessés dans la
description physique et morale que
j'avais brosse et dupont gaulin mais tu
sais c'était pour de rire
ouais mais n'empêche que ça peut faire
de la peine du sras pango là ça
m'étonnerait vraiment sa tasse rigoler
tu vois il me montrait du doigt le
passage incriminé le pangolin mesure 1 m
sa femelle s'appelle lapin golin elle ne
donne le jour qu'à un seul petit à la
fois qui s'appelle toto le pont gaulin
ressemble à un artichaut à l'envers
prolongée d'une queue à la vue de
laquelle on se prend à penser que le
ridicule ne tue plus j'en reconnais que
j'ai tapé fort le mot ridicule est un
peu dur c'est ça qui te gêne ah non ça
c'est rien c'est toto c'est toto totaux
c'est complètement idiot pour un
pangolin au fait qu'est-ce que tu
connais toi des pangolins ben nous quand
j'étais en vacances en côte d'ivoire
mais on avait un point gaulle 1 et il
est mort sous un camion
j'avais j'avais lâché saleh s'il voulait
pourra se promener en laisse ah oui
c'est ça alors tu as eu de la peine et
aujourd'hui tu n'aime pas trop qu'on se
moque des pangolins ben oui pauvre
gérard a pas ce qu'ils appelaient gérard
oui dis donc dans tes conneries pour la
radio le mercredi tu devrais parler des
pangolins pour que les enfants qui ont
lu ton livre ils voient bien que c'était
pour de rire
je me sentis assez flatter l idée que ma
mauvaise image de marque dans son école
lui était pénible alors bon rectificatif
le pangolin le pangolin du malais pang
holding qui signifie à peu près pango
l'un est un mammifère édenté d'afrique
et d'asie qui se nourrit de fourmis et
de termites
il mesure 1 m son corps est couvert des
cayes très très belle il ne ressemble
pas du tout à un artichaut ça que
s'arrête juste bien quand il faut c'est
formidable quand il a faim le pont
goller à un truc que même dans la jungle
aucun faux ville et même pas cap
tellement qu'ils auraient les boules
d'abord il trouve une fourmilière grâce
à son flair super avec son nez pointu et
ses griffes super il s'enfonce au milieu
de la fourmilière après ils en trouvent
toutes ces écailles très très belle qui
sont de la taille d'une petite feuilles
d'artichaut mais très très belle à ce
moment là le pont gaulle a réfléchi très
fort avec sa concentration et une petite
goutte sucrées comme du miel se met à
chanter sous chaque écailles et alors
toutes les fourmis des milliers des
millions de fourmis se jettent dessus et
le pangolin sans rigoler alors que ça
chatouille mais il est super concentré
le pangolin attend que les fourmis soit
arrivé et claque il referme tout les
écailles après il sort de la fourmilière
tu vas dans un coin tranquille
il rouvre ses écailles il se secoue très
fort et les fourmis tombent autour et il
les mange c'est une bête formidable sauf
qu'elle traverse sans regarder ça c'est
très dangereux
la femelle du pangolin s'appelle lapin
golin elle donne le jour un seul petit à
la fois qui s'appelle du fira
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quant au mois de mars je le dis sans
aucune arrière pensée
ça m'étonnerait vraiment dit passent
l'hiver fait étonnant non
[Musique]